herr peter gestern ging es also schon
los für redet wie kam es denn dazu man
hatte sich ja eigentlich geeinigt und
auch unser gesundheitsministerien sparen
war ja alles andere als begeistert du
hast die bams vor dir liegen
ich will mal einmal kurz sagen was er
zur bank gestern gesagt hat denn er war
dann doch ein bisschen irritiert das ist
so früh schon los ging
er liess ausrichten über seinen sprecher
minister sparen wünscht ihm alles gute
und freut sich mit der ersten corona
geimpften deutschland das ist ein erster
wichtiger schritt raus aus dieser
pandemie
allerdings hatten wir mit allen
partnerländern in der eu und in den 16
bundesländern vereinbart am samstag an
alle auszuliefern und ab sonntag
gemeinsam mit den impfungen zu beginnen
was war denn jetzt da los ja also umgang
und der landkreis halberstadt harz
konnten es nicht ganz halten die
begründung aus dem harz ist ein bisschen
kurios man hat gesagt man wollte diesen
einen tag den der impfstoff an
haltbarkeit verliert jetzt nicht
vergolden
naja also mit der begründung kannst du
wenn du im supermarkt was und hast den
stücken butter gekauft wie alle in einem
jahr verfallen
die ist so ja auch nicht gleich gleich
am ersten tag die halten sich also noch
ein bisschen
es war unnötig aber gut schön für ewig
kreuztaler freuen wir uns darüber schön
es ist nicht gehört sich einfach einfach
nicht aber schwamm drüber
die erste frau aus geimpft